( chuckling )
Well, can I just say
I love it here
and I definitely wanna
be your housemate.
Awesome,
great, um...
I do need to warn
you about one thing.
So you haven't met
Amy yet, she's great.
She does have
a boyfriend
who comes over a
lot and they fight.
Oh, well, all couples
fight, I think.
Uh, it's crazy,
it's really shocking
the things that
they say to each other.
( voices approaching )
All your thoughts are...
Here we go.
...from elderly people,
from old people, yeah.
You know what you are,
you're a poop person.
I'm a poop person?
God pooped
in his hand,
threw it at earth
and you're that poop.
Oh, our Lord and Savior
poops in His hand?
You know what, I hope
you have to sneeze like...
and it just doesn't
happen for you.
I hope that you get
stuck in traffic lights
and you just miss
the green one!
( gasping )
I hope that the next time
that you go to a wedding
you're wearing the
same dress as someone else
and it becomes the
joke of the night.
You have to take
pictures with that person.
Well, I hope that next time you
watch an episode of "Homeland"
that the DVR cuts out before you
see scenes from the next week
so to find out
what happened
you have to just
like ask around the office
or look online like
a homeless person!
And I hope that the next
time you go to a concert
that the band doesn't play
the song you wanna hear
and instead, they just play
songs off their new album!
Oh, God!
Or like a jam session
or something...
I think we might need
to call the police.
Katia, get in here,
he's lost his damn mind!
Whoa, Oh, my God,
Oh, my God.
David, put
that down.
David, this
isn't you.
You don't wanna
do this.
( screaming )
( crying )
You need to leave
right now.
Is that what
you want, Amy?
What I want,
is for you to accidentally
sit on your cell phone.
And I want you to touch
four P's in a row
to someone you haven't
talked to in a long time.
You know what-- I hope the next
time that you take a shower
the shower curtain
clings to you
and no matter what you do,
you can't get it off you.
You can get it off you,
but for the rest of the day,
you never really
feel clean!
Get out!
He's sick.
And I'm not coming
back here ever.
Unless this
blows over.
( sobbing )
It's over now, okay?
He almost went
so insane...
I know.
There was a
moment there.
Hey, this is Karen.
She might move
in with us.
Hi.
You didn't even tell
me you're moving out,
you dumb ( bleep )?
I'm sorry you guys,
this is my boyfriend.
You know what?
You're the ( bleep )!
y don't you get
your ( bleep )
out of your
( bleep )!
Why don't you get the
( bleep ) out of your ears
and get your skank-ass
and get the rest of
your ( bleep ) out here.
You know what,
I hope you rot in hell
after you watch every single
person you love die.
You are a white trash
piece of ( bleep ).
You are the reason why your
stepmother killed herself.
Oh, my God!
Get back here.
You are a ( bleep )
( bleep ) ( bleep ).
She's great.
She's so cool.
Yeah, she's
really nice.